so last week we had a preview of this
axios interview
between donald trump and jonathan swann
which aired
last night i've reviewed the full
interview
and this is truly the stuff of legends i
actually
my vocabulary was not uh
powerful enough to accurately describe
the contents of this interview so i had
to spend a bunch of time today
reading jack london in order to expand
my vocabulary to be better prepared to
describe what it is that we are about to
see
that's a joke by the way this may
actually be
the most damaging interview to donald
trump
that i have ever seen if you thought the
chris wallace interview two weeks and
two days ago on fox news sunday was bad
and it was this is arguably even worse
and what's
particularly spectacular about this
interview
is that jonathan swann calls out and
confronts donald trump on all those
things i've been saying during the last
five months of coronavirus
somebody has to call him out somebody
has to confront him well jonathan swann
did it
when trump lied about we have the lowest
death rate
jonathan swann checked receipts and had
trump pulling out papers that trump
didn't even understand
when trump uses his bogus talking points
or phrases like
people are saying jonathan swann says
who is saying tell me exactly who is
saying
and trump is never actually able to say
referring to vague books or whatever
let which trump doesn't read let's look
at some of this and we'll talk through
it here's a series of hilarious fact
checks and weird claims from trump
during
the vote by mail portion of the
interview and trump tries to claim that
absentee and mail-in are two different
things in this election
swan says it's the same thing trump says
vote by mail is new
swann says it's been around since the
civil war this is really really great
stuff
we have a new phenomena it's called in
it's called mail in voting
where you send where a governor it's
been used as a civil war
in terms of the kind of the kind of
millions and millions
of ballots they've never it'll be it'll
be bigger this year because of the
pandemic bigger
not bigger massively bigger yeah so
they're going to send
tens of millions of ballots to
california all over the place who who's
going to get them
i have a friend who lives in westchester
county i send applications
with universal mail-in voting absentee
voting is okay if you have to apply you
have to go through a process you have to
apply for failure
look okay okay let's do concrete let's
do that they're sending out
applications governors millions of
ballots
no they're not there's applications
there's
no way you can go through a mail-in vote
without massive cheating i honestly
don't understand
this topic with wikileaks the republican
party has an extremely well-funded vote
by mail program
your campaign puts out emails telling
people to vote by
correct your daughter-in-law lara trump
she did robocalls in california saying
it's safe and secure mainland voting
let me tell you the republicans we have
no choice that was an all-mailing race
let me tell you we went through world
war ii
you went to the polls you've had my
involved insistence because of the china
virus
was supposed to stay home send millions
of ballots all over the country
millions and millions you know you could
have a case
where this election won't be decided on
the evening of november third absolutely
this election could be decided two
months later maybe two months but what's
wrong with the proper mailing
decided many months later i have to use
the phrase
it's a verbal inkblot test it's just
throwing stuff
all over the place trump is frequently
using this thing
we might not know the results on
election night okay
i mean shouldn't we prioritize accuracy
over speed like why would it be so bad
if we didn't know the results
on election night is it that trump won't
be able to sleep for five days
not knowing that it's conceivable that
he may not
knowing that he may have lost the
election now then a ton of the interview
was about coronavirus and this is a
portion that we're going to want to look
at very closely donald trump start
making incorrect
starts making incorrect claims about
deaths
in the united states and actually pulls
out paper
so let's step through it one piece at a
time because this is really historically
embarrassing stuff now if you're
watching and not just listening
you're going to notice that as donald
trump is looking at various charts and
graphs that he pulls out
he seems to even struggle what it is
that he's looking at and ends up handing
stuff to jonathan swan take a look at
this
look at some of these charts i'd love to
we're going to look
let's look and if you look at death yeah
start to go up again well right here
the united states is lowest in
numerous categories uh we're lower than
the world lower the lower than europe
in what in what so this is already
amazing donald trump says
we are lower than the world and jonathan
swann is visibly confused and says what
what does that even mean we're lower
than the world in what
and so then trump starts handing papers
to jonathan swann
and things start to escalate very
quickly take a look
right here here's case death
oh you're doing death as a proportion of
cases i'm talking about death as a
proportion
of population that's where the u.s is
really bad well
much worse than south korea germany et
cetera you can't you can't do that you
have to
have to go by you have to go by
where look here is the united states you
have to go by the cases the cases why
not as a proportional population
what it says is when you have somebody
that has
where there's a case oh okay the people
that live from those cases
this is brilliant i mean this this is
just this is exactly the confrontation
that donald trump has needed all along
trump continues to insist that
the reason our numbers are skewed are
the number of tests that we do
and he keeps talking about our death
rate relative to the testing rate
i've talked about this before the case
fatality rate is a rate of deaths
relative to tests and trump continues to
insist
that testing skews numbers which is what
he says is actually the problem
and swann points out you know deaths per
population
not deaths per test is really what
matters
and trump is just barely able to even
keep up cognitively
it's surely a relevant statistic to say
if the u.s
has x population and x percentage of
death of that population no versus south
africa
by the cases we'll look at south korea
for example 51 million population
300 deaths it's like it's crazy
that i do you think they're faking their
statistics south korea
and advanced countries have a very good
relationship with the country
but you don't know that now that's a
really important moment
this is sort of a white flag moment for
trump
when you can't argue the facts anymore
when you've been
beaten on the facts and your arguments
if you can even call them that
fall apart you call into question
whether we can believe anything whether
we can know anything like this is a
complete white flag because
it stops the conversation it's actually
a really common crutch it's a basic
epistemological question that in a sense
we can always ask right you can always
turn to
how do we know anything how can we
uh what what really is true can we know
anything but
this is a crutch that stops the
conversation because it's like well then
anything you're saying is also subject
to that same question
it is a white flag when it is an
interview about facts
at any point you want you can always say
how do we know any fact is true
okay but that's not really where you go
if the facts are on your side and if
you're able to coherently put together
an
argument and trump then goes back to
holding up pieces of paper
that even he doesn't understand and just
continues handing them to the
interviewer
and they have spikes look here germany
low 9 000.
here's one right here united states you
take the number of cases okay look
we're last meaning we're first lost i
don't know what we're facing
as a whole again it's cases okay um and
we have cases
i mean these are majestic thousand
americans i understand
i understand on cases it's different no
but you're not reporting it correctly
jonathan
i think i am but if you take a look at
this other chart
look this is our testing i believe this
is the testing yeah
yeah we do more tests now wait a minute
well don't we get credit for that
and because we do more tests we have
more cases in other words we test more
we have
now take a look the top one that's a
good thing not a bad thing
at the top jonathan if if if hospital
rates were going down and deaths were
going down i'd say terrific you deserve
to be praised for testing but they're
all going in are they very
possibly sixty thousand americans are in
hospital you watch thousands
read the papers they usually talk about
new cases new cases new cases
i'm talking about death will you look
it's good enough death is way down from
where it was
it's a thousand a day it was two that
half thousand it went down to 500 now
it's going up again
the scariest part about this is that
under the most basic questioning like
these are simple pushbacks from jonathan
swan these aren't gotchas
this is what trump should have been
confronted with all along
he immediately becomes incoherent he has
to fall back on repeating things that
don't make sense
and you really get the sense that trump
doesn't understand what's going on
yes he also doesn't care but it's not
just that he doesn't care
he also doesn't get it he can't parse
the data he can't understand the facts
and here trump is confronted about his
constant refrain
that coronavirus is quote under control
when it's very clearly
completely out of control and take a
look at donald trump's response
they listen to every word you say they
hang on everybody they don't listen to
me or the media or fouchy they think
we're fake news
they want to get their advice from you
and so when they hear you say
everything's under control don't worry
about wearing masks
i mean these are people many of them are
older people more serious of control
yeah under the it's giving them a false
security i think it's under control i'll
tell you what how
a thousand americans are dying a day
they are dying that's true
and you ha it is what it is but that
doesn't mean we aren't doing everything
we can
it's under control that's really bad
right i mean
a thousand deaths a day this interview
was recorded a week ago we've had a
couple 14
1500 death days since and trump says
well it is what it is but it's under
control
either donald trump doesn't understand
language
or he will not concede ever
that this may not be under control but
trump just repeats it's under control
the deaths they are what they are but
it's under control it's like language
has no meaning anymore
and then they get back into testing and
cases take a look at that
i mean i've heard you say this big
countries don't test like we do
so they don't showcase it just a couple
of points on that i wasn't going to
continue on the testing but
you said it so we're testing so much
because it's spread so far in america
we're testing
so much because we had the ability to
test okay because we came up with
south korea jonathan we weren't even we
didn't even have a test when i took over
we didn't even have a test
now in all fairness why would you have a
test no test didn't exist
how would you ever talk okay there was
no test for this no
we didn't have a test because there was
no testosterone
in a very short order we got one test we
got another test it was broken
many of those tests are now obsolete
because we've you know it's called
science and
all of a sudden something's better so
jonathan swann here
doing a good job of calling out the
talking point that trump keeps using
that before trump was in office there
was no test for coronavirus yeah that's
right it's
a novel virus it's called uh covet 19
because of the year 2019 and
sometimes it seems trump is trying to
use this phrase we had no test when i
took over
to place blame on obama which is really
crazy
but sometimes what trump tries to use
that talking point for
is to say that the u.s was in a uniquely
difficult position relative to other
countries listen
we didn't have a test when i became
president but that was the case for
every country
in other words it was not just the u.s
that was facing a novel coronavirus with
no test
no other country had a test for it
because it was a novel coronavirus
nobody had a test and yet other
countries were able to get the virus
under control
let's keep going in this part of the
interview but because we tested
so many people 55 60 million people very
soon
we get cases you test some kid has even
just a little runny nose it's a case
and then you report many cases so we
look like we have more cases than
massive countries like china which by
the way doesn't report as you know
i i don't put any stock in china's point
is the point is
because we are so much better at testing
than any other country in the world
we show more cases now as you probably
know by now if you've been watching my
show
this is not true in terms of per capita
testing the united states has now crept
up to 18th in the world but the
important thing to understand
as jonathan swann attempted to point out
earlier is that
at this point a lot of countries don't
need to test
so now arguing we are doing the most
testing
even if true which it's not is no longer
equally relevant because the game is to
develop a testing program
early there are many countries now that
the us
is passing in tests per capita over time
because those countries don't have sim
people with symptoms they don't have
people to test because they have so few
cases early on remember when we were
50th 55th in testing per capita
that was the time to be testing to to
suppress the spread of the virus
many countries have done that so at this
point even bragging
about our testing per capita rate
becomes less relevant because
even though it's still only 18th in the
world a lot of the countries we've
passed since the countries
that are 25th 30th 40th in testing per
capita
they don't have anybody to test anymore
because they have so few cases it's
all just basic critical thinking and
stats stuff from high school
that trump doesn't get now at one point
donald trump was asked
about the recent passing of congressman
john lewis a civil rights hero
who trump barely acknowledged previously
and check out what donald trump says
immediately making it all about him
john lewis is lying in state in the us
capital how do you think history will
remember john lewis i don't know
i really don't know uh i don't know i
don't know john
lewis he chose not to come to my uh
inauguration he chose i don't
i never met john lewis actually i don't
believe do you find him impressive
uh i can't say one way the other i find
a lot of people impressive i find many
people not impressive but
no but i didn't find his story he didn't
come to my inauguration
he didn't come to my state of the union
speeches and that's okay that's his
right
and again nobody has done more right
more americans than i have i understand
he should have come but i think he made
a big mistake but
taking your relationship with him out of
it do you find his story impressive what
he's done
for this country he was a person that
devoted a lot of energy and a lot of
heart
to civil rights but there were many
others also
i don't know him he didn't come to my
inauguration he says twice
uh and i am the savior of black people
is what donald trump manages to turn
that into
trump cannot comment on anything outside
of his own relationship to the person or
the event or the material in question
and trump doesn't all lives matter here
this is equivalent to all lives matter
trump is asked about john lewis's
contributions to civil rights
and trump says lots of people
contributed to civil rights
that is again like well we're we're
talking here about
the victims of the boston marathon well
but people also died
in 9 11.
black lives matter well all lives matter
okay yeah but we're talking about black
lives right now
what about john lewis who just passed
away's contributions to civil rights
many people worked on civil rights
sick really really sick and then here's
our sort of uh dessert our denim on
trump once again wishing well to a
serial accused
child sex trafficker ji len maxwell
nice way to cap off the interview go all
over the country mr president the other
day a reporter asked you about galaine
maxwell
you said quote i just wish her well
frankly i've met her numerous times over
the years especially since i lived in
palm beach
but i wish her well whatever it is mr
president maxwell
has been arrested on allegations of
child sex trafficking
why would you wish such a person don't
know that but i do know that she has
she's been arrested for that her
friend or boyfriend epstein was either
killed or committed suicide in jail
she's now in jail yeah i wish you well
i'd wish you well i'd wish a lot of
people well
good luck let them prove somebody was
guilty i mean you do you know this
oh so you're saying you hope she doesn't
die in jail is that what you mean by
wish her well
her boyfriend died in jail and people
are still trying to figure out
how did it happen was it suicide was he
killed
and i do wish her well i'm not looking
for anything bad for her i'm not looking
bad for
anybody and they took that and i mean
she's a child sexually allegedly
big deal but all it is is her boyfriend
died he died in jail was he killed was
it suicide
i do i wish her well famous last words
maybe from donald trump i have never
seen anything like this
i thought 16 days ago that the fox news
chris wallace interview
was rock bottom as far as interviews are
concerned
no this is far far worse let me know
your thoughts i'm on
twitter at dpakman and remember that you
can get the daily audio
podcast excuse me the daily audio
podcast of the show
every single day right around 3 p.m
eastern time on whatever is your
favorite podcasting app
spotify google play pandora
iheartradio itunes whichever you prefer
get the daily audio podcast we'll take a
quick break
and be right back real quick i want to
tell you about our sponsor
magic spoon who have done something
awesome they've taken all of our
favorite sugary childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar-free
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n